I just can't it's too stressful welcome
inside time All-Star critics Granderson
Philly's legend Jimmy Rollins jayroll
the Hall of Famer Pedro Martinez there
is so much good Alec Thomas at the top
of the list but that sound at the top of
the postgame show Craig Kimbrell in a
safe situation it was the eighth inning
and you talked about it before the show
what did you think watching him uh I I
actually felt bad for Thompson
pretending that Kimbell was going to
give him more than three outs not only
he went through 24 laboring pitches last
night but he failed and and at the same
time you asking him to do too much today
even though you have the lead six out
today it's a a little bit too much to
ask from Kimbro a guy that's not
consistently in the strike zone uh
doesn't have really command of the
breaking ball or the fast ball and
normally when he comes around in the
strike zone now it's not like when when
he was a little bit younger that he had
98 to 100 to blow it by you he's now 94
to 95 miles on hour and anytime he gets
into the strike zone he pays and that's
exactly what happened today I I was
really against Kim bro for more than one
inning at that point I thought Thompson
was was going to start like thinking mix
and match maybe albarado croses it and
Kimbro faces the first righties that
that pop up in this inning that I could
live with but leaving Kimbro out there
to blow the lead I I I don't agree with
that and I know that that that it could
have been great if Kimbro was able to
close it but at that point when you have
the lead and you haven't had that many
uh opportunities to get the lead you
have to be thinking a barado Kimbro
depending on how many lefties or how
many righties are coming those are the
two guys that you have to finish your
game and end up with the win it will go
down as a blown save for him I was
watching thinking it's the sum of the
parts in October right it's the walks
it's the bullpen moves and it's the
swing of Alec Thomas's life a moment he
won't soon forget and Evan Loria said it
we have better at bats as the G as the
game goes on and lavulo made another
change there pinch hitting bringing Alec
Thomas in in that situation against a
closer doesn't matter if he didn't do
what he's supposed to do Kimber in that
situation he's still a closer ER still a
tough at bat he's not all around the
plate so how do you lock him in the
first two balls he swung at fouled him
behind him fouled him behind him but
then finally got a ball out over the
plate does that then the next step at
you got Alvarado in there throwing a
million miles an hour and you go ahead
and do a single to go ahead and get your
team on top now Jimmy you and I always
talk about this over the course of 162
games the stars are going to get their
numbers but on October anyone can have
the moment this moment is his and and it
and is it's a great moment for him a kid
coming off the bench
uh something really difficult to do yeah
very very difficult to do especially
this time of year and I'm sure it's
something that he's not used to you know
he starts he platoons a little bit but
coming off the bench in this situation
with the game on the line feeling like
okay I have to do something aren't you
supposed to be nervous at that age of
course you're nervous but you take one
swing it's like okay now we're in theat
and we were watching him it's like if he
takes he probably walks here he took
swung some pitches in off the plate but
it was just getting them loose and
that's kind of getting your nerves out
Kell missed out over the plate and the
pitch is probably about a inch and a
half two inches off the plate but it's
on the barrel it was flat as Pedro said
he's is no longer 98 with that ride on
it it's 94 he put it good B up and he
put put his team on his shoulders and
I'm proud of that almost made you cry
well I had a teer but I couldn't let
y'all see it he couldn't he couldn't
show any weakness he couldn't Brian
Anderson with the call uh the kids won
it for the Arizona Diamond Backs lucky
us we get to see you tomorrow night a 1
hour pregame show we get to hang with
you again game five of the National
League Championship Series same time
same place on Saturday we can't wait
8:07 Eastern your first pitch Jimmy what
time is our coverage uh 7:30 you got it
Booker yeah on hand the old school
camter was a true Bullpen game for
Arizona Christopher Sanchez hoping to
give the Phillies some length a little
defense on display yes please JT real
Muto watch lordis guriel Jr the leaping
catch at the wall the Rob at least an
extra base showing that athleticism from
the best athletes out there of course
look at the hype look at the
congratulations look at the
reaction I give you credit for that I
give you L's a little credit for that he
also had a big hit in the eighth did
guriel the Diamond Back strike first in
the bottom of the second Emanuel Rivera
easy peasy up the middle singles scoring
Christian Walker and Arizona is on the
board one to nothing make it two to
nothing in the third Gabriel Morena this
guy's 23-2 just past rookie status young
in his career and has had had some
gigantic moments in the postseason an
RBI single scoring catel Marte and it's
two nothing Diamondbacks watch this what
the that's what they go bomb it it's
ridiculous really most home runs by
left-handed batter and postseason
passing Reggie Jackson 19 of them it is
a missile to right center field should
count for two solo shot well scho bad is
not going to get the the the label of Mr
October only one I got it I got Brandon
Marsh what a moment swinging a hot bat
man he's been good six game hitting
streak for him a double to left center
field scoring is JT realmuto and we are
tied tie ball game gentlemen at two runs
a piece I want you to watch this in the
top of the six with nobody out Bas is
loaded Alec bom grounds to third fair or
foul what do you think Fair ball he
called it fair it's not reviewable but
my goodness Manuel Rivera throws home
short hops The Catcher And two runs will
score you thought fair right off the bat
I mean the ball bounces in front of the
play when he catches itar has to make a
determination it's high in the air and
although it was going to end up foul it
was going to cross the back fair and
that's where they make the call Pedro
what do you think I I think it was fair
because uh at the time he went across
the back was in Fair Ground was this the
match up to lell wanted or not his
Slugger against a rookie Orion kirkin
gets it and then gets paven Smith to
ground out to First inning over three
left on base a Miss opportunity the
eighth was magic for Arizona that lead
evaporated in an instant Alec Thomas
into the pool bottom of the eigh 23 the
swing of his leg forcing fast ball down
the middle is of the plate I mean he was
starting that to stay in I'm not saying
it that is a ding Splash stop it on the
double Splash every angle getting better
and better he was going in in in and
that at
back don't jump in a lot of people
jumping into the
pool oh thank you Jose Alvarado into the
game Gabriel Moreno adding one for good
measure in the bottom of the eighth with
Runners on first and second and he was
just and that was 100 that was 100 and
he goes ahead let me go ahead and get
that right there and then Paul
sewald to Kyle schwarber giving the
philes life in the top of the nine as a
two out hit Arizona leads by one so some
opportunity for Tre Turner and the
Philly's lineup is ridiculous because
you got Trey Turner you got Bryce Harper
coming up and he has been swinging a hot
bat has Trey Turner for seing fastball
by Paul seaal gets him and it is all
tied up the series at two games a piece
wow pretty incredible six to five your
final score in the desert one more game
tomorrow night before they head back to
the bank which is going to be what Jimmy
Rollins rocking it is going to be insane
Pedro Martina is that oh gosh Roman
Roman knows what's up Roman's been
watching a Tuesday night on TVs you know
Rob Thompson was asked about a bullpen
game he was asked what he thought of it
and he did not mince words he said I
hate it it's a challenge for everyone at
the plate you know this because it's for
for the Diamond Backs every arm angle
Jimmy it's up here it's up here it's
down here that's a challenge no not only
that I mean you you're accustomed to
facing different arm angles but not
every inning and not that you come up
with an aat every inning you just go
into the game with the game plan for
each game you have a game you're not
sure what what's going to come out when
they're going to come out so it's kind
of like spring training this time of
year and how do you go up there with the
game plan a situation yes a situation
tells you what to do but usually as
you're going over your hitters meeting
this guy likes to do this and this count
this percentage Runners and scoring
position position EX Etc when it's a
bullpen game it's like okay well who's
next in a hitters meeting you're
practicing for all of those guys you're
studying them all no no just starter
exactly and that's what makes it so
difficult and you don't know when
they're all going to come in but also at
the same time the Phillies have been
dominant their bull pin's been amazing
we've been talking about it but over
time at some point you're going to be
able to get to them and they were able
to get to them tonight especially when
they rolled all of them out there and it
shows once you get to the playoffs
backto Back Games you're kind of limited
you don't have a starter to go ahead and
get you five or six Innings like you've
had the first three games what can our
Bullpen do that's already starting to
get taxed then to go start to get taken
advantage of tonight like they were able
to Bullpen moves are the ticket to the
promised land in October that's a
t-shirt by the way I like it